jetzt spielen wir hier sozusagen
operation ja wohl daraus der brauch von
der franziskas aussagen und wir sehen
dass wir jetzt vielleicht der blinddarm
von der franziskaner die kümmern sich
greifen mit der so und jetzt es auf die
deutsche szene nachdem man jahre haben
wir andere hatte das alles was in
deutschland mäßig passiert einfach nur
eine kopie von dem ist was in den usa
gerade läuft einfach ein bisschen später
auch deutsche gekommen ist kam in den
letzten monaten und halben jahr ja
vielleicht so in deutschland eine
richtige mimik szene auf und aus
irgendeinem grund bestätigte - szene zu
99 prozent aus alten fernsehsender
jetzt mal im ernst heute das ist eine
sache die ich nicht kenne so das
kräftespiel von vater stammt aus
irgendeinem jahre alten fernseher video
stammt aus einer fernsehsendung und
jetzt gibt es neuerdings ganz aktuell
willi will's wissen als mich fragt mich
nicht warum ausgerechnet jetzt willi
will's wissen - aufkommen aber sie sind
da leute und sie sind lustig und sie
sind extrem aus dem kontext gerissen
wir schauen uns hier heute an etwas eine
kleinigkeit unterscheidet mich von euch
ich kann gehen das thema ja leute okay
wir sind das hier fasst sich an den kopf
und deswegen muss ich hier gab es noch
eine sache sagen die ganze sache sind
wie gesagt aus dem kontext gerissen die
methode von willi will's wissen es hat
auch weil ist in einem video gesagt war
früher dass er sich bewusst umgestellt
hat bewusst naive fragen gestellt hat
und gesprochen hat die ein kind weil
williamson der kindersendung ist und
sich kinder so damit identifizieren
können wenn man aber jetzt dieses
kindische denken diese kindischen setzte
die bewusst gesagt wurden aus dem
kontext nimmt kann entstehen solche
absurden situationen also leute wenn ihr
diese clips hier sehen dann immer im
hinterkopf behalten dass willi mit sehr
hoher wahrscheinlichkeit ein sehr
liebenswürdiger mensch ist und ich mich
radikal und ganz klar von jeglicher
diskriminierung distanziere
und ja nichts ich hoffe mal rein und
gucken wie lustig dieses video sind
wasser
was ist bei uns im überfluss gibt ist in
tansania sehr knapp sagt immer wir in
deutschland war fragen würden wenn man
wirklich das was wir auch wichtig dass
gerade eben noch mal zu sagen leute
diese sache nicht vorneweg schickt dass
das immer extremer so kontext gerissen
ist und die art von willi ist so zu
reden dann könnte man diese videos sehen
und sich denken
es gibt bei emails ab ich liebe willi
will's wissen
das würde ich an dieser stelle einfach
nur sagen der typ ist auch meine
kindheit wie auch sicher die kindheit
von einigen von euch leute wir können
uns also schon leute wir können darüber
lachen eben weil wir wissen dass ist ja
bewusst also kontext genommen ist selber
sind immer auf dem friedhof oder gräber
sind meistens auf dem friedhof marsa
alam willi also gut ich meinen kummer
leute wäre die sendung folge schaut also
ob es waren höchstwahrscheinlich kinder
die unter 10 sind so also die fragen
sind ja wirklich sehr sehr einfach
gestellt aber ganz ehrlich ich feiere
dass ich falls ich habe schon oft gesagt
ich fand dass wir die bestehende sich
entwickelt hat in deutschland und nicht
für das ist auch dass das jetzt so ein
ding ist gerade leider gibt es dann so
leute wie manuell sind die ihn jetzt
also ein rapper die jetzt ihn beleidigen
dafür und so da schickt natürlich meinen
kopf aber ja
die hand geben aber ich darf niemand
hören den darf ich gar nicht anfassen
aber erst das okay also er konnte jetzt
in den op rein und ist zudem typisches
kind liegt da ist das kind über par
ansprechbar
es ist es amtlich es am leben ok soll
warmherzig gehen
so will willi ist ein fucking ernst
gerade ich komme gerade aus einer op
oder ich werde gleich operiert ich hab
gerade andere probleme als für die ich
deine sendung was du kriegen kannst du
mich in ruhe lassen last legt los und
ich drücke die daumen
es ist aber auch mehr geld zusammen
geschnitten schon ein trikot oder dieses
video gemacht lasst euch von mir nicht
aufhalten steht mitten im op mit einem
kamerateam nutzen
also sorry aber also wie gesagt ich habe
gerade eben schon gesagt dass willis
methode war sich dumm zu stellen um so
bisschen auf diese nicht dumm oder anna
f einfach nur ein einfacher
denkstrukturen mit kindern ihren bezug
herstellen zu können
aber willi war das nicht ein bisschen zu
sex will jetzt mal ganz ehrlich also ich
glaube nicht dass kinder darunter zehn
wenn sie einen skorpion denken den
übertrag von staffellauf penis sage ich
mal machen okay das war's du das machen
sich mit 14 aber nicht mit 8 1
rechenaufgabe 2 + 2 3 + 3
nein aber normalerweise ein kind kann
schon 33 mit sechs jahren zusammen wir
sind nicht die leute ich bin wirklich
froh dass ich dieses disclaimer
vornherein gemacht habe dass ich mich
wirklich ganz klar vor jeglicher
diskriminierung distanzieren würde ist
so gecancelt werden heutzutage in
deutschland werde das hochladen würdest
und ganz ehrlich leute finde ich schade
finde ich schade also versteht mich
nicht falsch ich bin natürlich wie jeder
normale vernünftiger mensch gegen
diskriminierung aber so diese kultur von
politiker korrekt dass dies mittlerweile
in deutschland auf der welt gibt ist da
hab ich schon so extrem dass man so eine
kindersendung die so für kinder gemacht
ist auch so nicht mehr machen könnte
heutzutage ich glaube das würde
heutzutage nicht mehr gehen jetzt
spielen wir hier sozusagen operation ja
wohl sagen und wir sehen dass wir jetzt
vielleicht der blinddarm von der
franziskaner die kann man sich greifen
mit der so und jetzt es auf
[Musik]
das ist also ich habe es ja gerade
erklärt aber ich komme nicht um dieses
denken wenn man diese clips dass man
sich zumindest spaßeshalber willi so als
so geisteskranken vorstellt
also wir den druck ich liebe dich aber
diese clips kann man so brutal aus dem
kontext nehmen das ist beginnen sie war
damals ja willi will's wissen heute
episode 261 wir werden heute den
blinddarm von franziska entnehmen und
dann verspeisen liebe kinder wenn ihr
zuhause mitmachen wollt dann sucht euch
einfach ein familienmitglied und ein
küchenmesser und dann läuft das auch man
vermutet immer dass er sich bewegt muss
halt etwas tut man nicht ist tot
nein nein nein nein nein nein nein das
akzeptiere ich nicht nein nein also viel
tun gar nicht dass das ist nicht will
dass nicht wie das sind schauspieler
dann also darum geht es heute auch um
das thema hören und wie menschen die
kaum oder gar nichts hören damit
zurechtkommen meine erste station heute
die samuel heinicke realschule in
münchen
die klasse 6 b h der kommt aber wirklich
wirklich nicht gut weg in diesen chips
sogar gangsta rap haben angst vor diesem
mann ja natürlich glaubt man nicht dass
irgendeiner von uns gut weg kommen würde
wenn er mit willi in einem raum ist
willi würde uns die ehre stibitzen aber
wirklich in sekundenschnelle komm mal
her ist er mit dem rollstuhl flink bist
du auf flink auf den beinen oder
bei willi wirklich versucht hier die
ganze zeit in schutz zu nehmen
merkst du merkst du dich da vorgemerkt
sollte also wohin dieses video gesehen
das geht überhaupt nicht wenn sie das
schwert zu überlegen mit dem kopf es ist
ein problem das ist ein problem
ja woher kommt mein live.com twilight
der gerade da kann ich aber auch die
leighton also ich wie gesagt ich diese
ganzen sache sind komplett aus dem
kontext können deswegen weiß ich auch
gar nicht
er hat der junge hat wahrscheinlich eine
krankheit ich weiß nicht welcher das ist
aber so habe ich mich in der einen oder
anderen klausur in der uni auch schon
geführt muss ich sagen oder wenn sie den
quatsch vorbeiläuft und irgend kumpel
von mir stellte seine frage so geht es
geht jetzt nicht ich kann sich denken
ich bin der willi und ja ich wollte mal
wo ich unterricht zu schauen
also ich glaube die haben mich jetzt gar
nicht so richtig verstanden
toll toll beliebte versuchen sachlich zu
analysieren ok nich wat jetzt schicke
ich auch willi dass das nämlich genau
die methode willi ist an der schule für
gehörlose glaube ich jetzt gerade also
für kinder die leider nicht hören können
und jetzt schickt nämlich so langsam die
methode ist auch mal am praktischen
beispiel er vermittelt den kindern mit
diesem ultra stumpfen ansatz dass er so
erst mal versucht mit den ja sag ich mal
mit ihm mit mit tauben care einfach noch
mal zu reden dass man eben mit tauben
kindern nicht normal reden kann mit
menschen die man hören kann also diese
ultra stumpfen methoden greifen eben wie
es schon gesagt hat das vorweg was
kinder denken würden um quasi dazu
führen dass kinder den fehler in echt
nicht machen
hallo ich hätte gerne eine million euro
und klein schneiden dankeschön perfekt
war es gibt es auch willi den op
infiziere nicht desinfiziert sondern
infiziere willi den diskriminiere und
will den bankräuber aber was vergessen
leute ach ja wie soll man das überhaupt
mein wille der einer beerdigung sachen
und sagt die anbieten werden ich will
dich nicht auf den gedanken bringen aber
noch hast du zeit den anzug auszuziehen
und die aus dem staub zu machen
lieber nicht also dass es dann wieder so
was zwischen wo ich mir denke willi sie
verstehen zu also du willst jetzt kinder
nehmen wir so eine hochzeit näher
bringen was war passiert
ich glaube ich glaube leute in manchen
fällen jetzt hier zum beispiel mit
dieser hochzeit er hat wahrscheinlich
willi auch mal so diese narrenfreiheit
genutzt die als kinder moderator eben
hat um auch selbst mal so ein bisschen
fängt anspruch zu machen der ihn selbst
ein bisschen belustigt hat ich bin mega
reise und held meiner kindheit jetzt auf
youtube wieder zu finden heute und wenn
ihr nicht wollt dass willi zu euch kommt
und euch los dann checke ich
vorgeschlagen es wieder ab abonniert
hier um einen kanal ich bin und erstellt
daraus macht gut